Hello everyone.
It's April 25th.
20, 22.
We're here with Adam Safron, and today
we're going to be having a guest stream
the radically embodied,
conscious cybernetic Bayesian brain
from free energy
to freewill and back again.
So, Adam,
thanks a ton for joining us on this day.
Really looking forward
to your presentations.
And thanks again, Adam.
Take it away.
Thank you for inviting me and
letting me come to talk with you
and to present some.
Ideas from a recent manuscript
in Entropy called
the Radically Embodied Conscious
Cybernetic Bayesian Brain and Free Will.
From free energy
to free will and back again.
And After that.
Looking forward to discussing
similar ideas with all of you and
hopefully this is a beginning of.
An ongoing. Conversation.
So what I tried to.
Do with this manuscript was basically.
Marry.
Good old fashioned cognitive science
with a more an activist perspective,
trying to find a middle way
between these ways of doing things and
this is a view that I've come to over
a number of years where.
The idea. Being that embodiment like.
You have.
At this point, you know, it's not news
that the mind is embodied.
But the.
Claim is that it is very, very embodied,
some would say radically.
Embodied.
I'm not sure if that made the most sense
to use that term,
because the term radical
with respect to embodiment
is usually pointing
to a perspective or radical and activism.
That avoids.
Talking about representations or models
and instead is saying,
you know, what's really going on
is these couplings with the world.
And maybe you can say
there's like an implicit information
processing or intelligence
even that might be objected to.
But these talk of.
Representations and symbols
and models from cognitive science.
That's those are not things.
And so this paper goes
through a perspective in which basically.
We do have.
Representations and models,
and we also have
these sort of inactive couplings.
With the world.
And as.
I say, it's radical in that nearly
every mental process you care to talk.
About.
The way you have to understand it,
according to this view, would be first
and fundamentally and foremost
in terms of its embodied character.
So I move.
On as a everything coming across clearly.
Just around the.
Yeah, I did disable my video because due
to some incredible consequences
of different situations,
I'm using a hotspot but it's all good.
OK, when you're on the run
I thought, hmm.
So review a little background.
I mean, a lot of this
people who were watching this.
With.
Or our view,
some background on predictive processing
and active inference,
maybe some of. Our.
Present is somewhat heterodox to.
All of that's.
Also something to. Discuss.
So a basic account of predictive coding,
you have these deep pyramidal neurons
and you have these superficial parameter
variants.
Where.
They're deep with respect to cortex
as having this layered structure.
Of. Roughly six layers
with some variations on the theme
depending on where you look.
And the idea is that.
The cortex as a whole is engaging in
what's sometimes called hierarchical
or what's often called hierarchical
predictive coding
or potentially predictive processing,
because there might be some assumptions
with saying predictive coding
that not everyone would
sign up for, such as that
you are only suppressing
and explaining away information
as opposed to
sometimes enhancing it.
And there's other nuances
that could make people object
to syncretic coding
instead of getting into those weeds.
The idea would be
that you have this hierarchy.
Of beliefs.
Implicit in neuronal organization,
the nature of these beliefs,
and this gets into these debates
about representation and and activism.
But this idea that.
I. Can say there's an implicit belief
at each neuron and set of neurons
about what they expect,
what patterns they expect to encounter.
And according to this predictive
processing you, through their activity,
they're trying to. Predict.
This incoming activity and suppress it
or explain it away.
To minimize overall activity,
and that you only update these beliefs
where you got it
wrong via a prediction error.
And this is. Under.
Certain assumptions.
If you have a good model
and events in the.
World are.
Relatively slow relative
to your internal signaling units,
you can have substantial
energetic savings or an organ of about
2% of your body
mass and 20% of your metabolism
seems like the kind of thing
natural selection would do.
And some decent evidence for. This
So this.
So the basics of moral architecture here
for Cortex is viewing it as a predictive
processing hierarchy or a hierarchy
and that each of your.
Models would.
Be a different belief hierarchy,
and they would. All.
Come together and exchange information
for a joint belief
across all your modalities
in terms of what you think
should be in your sensorium
as it moves through the world,
whether it's the world you're in
right now or some sort of
counterfactual world
in the present or future.
So that's predictive
processing in a nutshell.
And so in this account,
the goal was to use
predictive processing
to try to get into the micro mechanics
of goal oriented behavior and agency
And so what I suggested is that
work has been
done within act of inference.
On this sort of.
Imaginative. Plan.
Pursuing the. Goals on the.
Work to refer to
would be unsophisticated inference
or sophisticated affective inference,
which is.
Thinking about.
Basically planning into the future
as this tree search of possibility,
scrambling on different
branches of these possibilities.
And then picking the ones either
in imagination
or in reality
that would correspond to you
minimizing your prediction
or the best or realizing value the best.
But this exploration
of a tree of possibilities
and going down different branches.
And so this would be,
I suppose, a particular flavor of this.
And the idea being that.
A lot of it.
Would be pulling along this stream
of consciousness of imaginings.
Would.
Be this iterative comparison
between sensed
and imagined states
or between various goals states.
So here. I.
Have this comic book
that a friend helped me make.
And I have multiple.
Comics throughout.
I tend to view comics as being.
Really.
Highly expressive in a way that I think
we should probably use them more in terms
of being able to capture the joints
and experience space
with sufficient richness and detail.
And there could even be something
like comic book ask
about the stream of experience,
which could be part of the reason
that they're so effective.
But for sure, in this.
Comic.
Or a modal frame sequence,
as I sometimes call it,
you see in the bottom here,
this is the actual pose of the agents
and up top,
what's going through the mind's eye,
whether we're talking about
and imagination or perception.
And so here it's just a simple
contrasting of what you're perceiving
at each given moment
and then what you're imagining.
So you're sitting you want t you
then look and you say,
I am not talking to you.
I'm at my computer
and there is a laptop in front of me.
You look down and you're imagining
having tea in your cup, but then you look
and there is indeed no tea.
And then you imagine a next step.
And so what's, what's happening here
is you're doing this contrasts.
And what I propose is that in contrasting
between these states,
they're arranging
they're basically setting up prediction
errors for each other
where what doesn't match
with potentially
get you a natural prioritization. Of.
What features are unaligned
and then from those
you use that to retrieve
some sort of relevant affordance
to help you bridge this gap
between your imagination and reality.
And there's a lot of devils in details
of the ways this could work, but
that some sort of iterative
contrasting of
goals, states and a goal hierarchy
where it's like
you might have an ultimate goal
but to achieve that goal, you have to now
go and think of
what are all of the sub steps
and the subgoals that would be needed
to actually get the T in my. Hand.
You're going to have to
ambulate to the kitchen,
make the tea, et cetera, et cetera.
And as you're going back and forth,
at some point, at some point,
you either have a plan that's compelling
enough or the next action is close
enough to your present post that you're
just find yourself launching into action,
sometimes accompanied
by a feeling of having decided.
Sometimes you just find yourself moving.
But that's the basic account here that
the stream
of consciousness is being pulled along
in this goal oriented fashion,
this value driven fashion,
sometimes more freely wandering,
but sometimes but but usually
there's an interest
and you're as an act of inference
and predictive
processing your preferences
or your attract insights attractors
that you'll find them as a system
which you're attracted
to takes the form of predictions.
And so the things in your mind
that you're imagining.
That.
They become the goal, they become
the state of the world that you prefer
in that instance or in general,
if it's a regular kind of imagining
and this now becomes the attracting state
that your system self organizes.
And you.
Engage
in action selection of different kinds to
minimize that difference
between what you're imagining.
And what you.
Are estimating for the. World
so I go.
Into some discussion. Of.
Neural architecture and different aspects
that might be more or less relevant
for different.
Aspects of.
This kind of stuff.
And I probably.
Should have just thrown this
on top of a picture of a brain.
But I didn't.
But in some ways
it might be a good thing.
And I wonder whether
this account
of having a dual tier system,
something like a system on in
a System two,
is a broader story than just brains.
And so, you know, I have we're not here.
Like here would be neural substrates
that would enable you to do this.
But well, it. Could be across brains.
You might have similar processes
happening
within, let's say, like an insect
nervous system by different means.
Like instead of the basal ganglia,
you might be using the mushroom.
Bodies.
For talking more like an ant colony,
for instance.
It's possible you have a different
like a tracking states of the colony
where some are
taking this role of like a higher level
controller and a lower level controller.
But the basic idea here
is that you have an upper level
controller that's capable of aggregate
information across different.
So you have this lower level process
and this control where the lower.
Level.
Is taking care
of your immediate couplings
with the world
this would be the more inactive portion.
If we're talking about the brain,
it would be something like
so loosely assembled. A.
Constellation. Of.
Cortical reactive dispositions,
maybe orchestrated
by the cerebellar system of
what would be called amortized inference
and would be largely unconscious
and automatic phenomena.
Ologists
would talk about just like things being.
Ready at hand.
As opposed to being present to hand.
You're just effortless engagement
and effortless mastery with the world.
But on top of this,
you have a slower process in this case,
I'm saying it's more involving conscious
processing, something more system
to like to use Kahneman's language.
Where.
It's involved in more deliberate
potentially effortful.
Modes.
Of cognition,
which would be a higher level.
Of control over this.
Faster, smooth coupling system.
So go into some details
of neural architecture.
Potentially this might be just.
What you.
Need for a lot of active
inferential agents,
something like this across whether or not
we're talking about neurons.
This this might be a broader story
for active inferential agents.
So to return.
To the example. Of. Making t
go into it some more single.
So we're back to the mappings
here in the in.
Areas associated with.
Mental.
Imagery, maybe even physical
and computational substrates of
mental imagery phenomenon
phenomenology itself like the Junius
for instance, involved in imagination
have heavily implicated.
Multiple. Reasons
to think why this was the case.
But, you know,
I have this little Cartesian theater here
with the different imaginings.
And down.
Below the idea is you are iterating
through different imaginings, imaginings,
largely via large scale
orchestration by the hippocampal complex.
And it's a capacities to couple
with the rest of the cortex
to guide these.
High.
Level tracking states
where some portions of which would be
your experience and so the reason you
bring up the hippocampus then here is
it seems to be a specialized subsystem
for sequential predictive modeling.
You can say that for cortex as a whole,
technically hippocampus
is a kind of cortex,
archaic cortex of old vintage,
but that basically so
Damasio will talk about this in terms
of a convergence divergence zone
where many things will funnel in
and then funnel
back with high centrality.
Of. Fresh
read his name, he said Waterloo,
the spawn architecture.
But he'll talk. About semantic pointers.
But there's different ways
of viewing this.
The high centrally set campus
as it basically
will predict this trajectory
of the overall organism through space.
You can both encode memories
what was happening in my story
and whether in reality or imagination.
At each point,
as I was moving through space and time
and you could also use it
for replay, including
in counterfactual circumstances.
And so I have.
Some diagrams here of the neural systems
involved.
And right here you would have the idea.
I think that's good for now.
So I wants to know more details
about that later.
We could.
So to a turn to.
Trying to go more phenomenological.
So these modal frame sequences or comics,
ultimately I'm trying to build up
to is a sufficiently detailed account
of neural architecture
and a sufficiently detailed account
of phenomenology that we can talk.
About.
So that we can basically talk about
something as highfalutin as free will
and have some purchase.
So in this.
Formal complex model sense,
once you have that up top.
An imagining.
Row below.
That, you have
what's actually in your perception.
Below that, you have your pose
and your proprioceptive
inference.
And then below that you have
your intercept of inference.
And so as.
You're stepping through,
the stream of consciousness is evolving
through space
and time encoded or orchestrated.
By the.
Hippocampal system at this high,
potentially most integrative
high level of action
selection, you are having different.
Walls in your body.
Corresponding
to the intercept of concomitant.
Of or.
The intercept of aspects of what it means
to be in different situations.
So for instance, like a hunger situation
here, you're getting prediction, error
intercept, a prediction that would be
roughly vaguely, vaguely localized.
Here is like a cool sensation
around your gut and mouth
or thirst or hunger, something like this.
And now as you're going into movement,
you might have here like
you're
still having this intercept of code.
Of hot.
And cold
say it's pleasant and unpleasant,
but it's kind of getting infused
into other modalities
where your proprioception,
some of the phenomenology of like
feeling like an urge in your body.
It's one of the claims I make
is that you have this kind of quasi
synesthetic cross mapping
which in intercepting signals signals
and the receptive and receptive
associates.
Are part.
Of the reason I claim this
and say that this is both part
of the phenomenology of will
and maybe part of the mechanism also
is that intercepts of signals
are purely localize able
in space and time that you tend
to have pretty low resolution for them.
And so they
may drift free from their sources
and as a kind of anomalous inference.
But an adaptively anomalous inference,
they may get infused into.
The. Relevant effector and sensory
systems and objects in the worlds
for which they would be relevant.
You know.
I make a lot of different claims in this
work from a number of years of study,
and a lot of it can be taken
la carte, like you can find
some things to be more compelling
some things to be less compelling.
But I do think you get a whole it's
greater than the sum of its parts, but
it can also be taken
in a piecemeal fashion.
So you might not be particularly
compelled by this account of interception
as being synesthetic in nature, but
nothing really.
Not too much will right on that.
But it nothing, none.
Of that much, much of what will follow
will right on that.
But it could end up being important.
So I'm putting it in there. OK.
And so
across all of this, this is happening
within a perspective
of computational neuro
phenomenology, as Neil Seth calls it.
I call it Marianne Neural Phenomenology.
And the reason I call it
Marianne is specifically
his account
of multiple levels of analysis, which
I guess supervision on each other.
And you can do two things
because things have these multiple levels
that they can be engaged with.
You can either engage with them ala carte
because of let's say, for instance,
you want to do cognitive science, but
you have no idea of how the brain works.
And then for many years we haven't.
And there's a lot of mystery.
So you can kind of bracket.
Like.
Here's this big set of unknowns,
but it's at a different level.
But we're looking at this other level.
We can obtain knowledge even though we
might be ignorant to these other levels.
And that would be, you know,
functionalism and cognitive science.
But for me, what's more exciting
about this, actually, this Marianne Stack
is the capacity not for independence
but interdependence
and mutual constraints
using the implementation level
or the mechanistic level as a constraint
of what's a likely set of algorithms,
using a likely set of algorithms
to test hypotheses
on the implementation level,
using what you think.
The emotions.
And things like neuropsychiatric
literature to constraint and then imaging
literature to constrain algorithm
and thereby implementation.
So the the idea of what excites me
is like filling in this
crossword puzzle strengths
and then cross-referencing them
with the phenomenon.
So that.
As a.
General of all.
I'm using basically machine
learning as the person principle,
particularly onto the basis of this idea
that a lot of cortex could be understood
terms the. Oracle pretty good.
But also evoking some additional machine
learning principles.
But that's the overall scope of it.
In terms of. The.
All the body parts and faces.
This is part of the radical embodiment
idea is that instead of like the cortex
being this like grab bag of associations
with areas.
And the why, the idea is once you.
Really place it
front and center
as a cybernetic controller
for an embodied embedded agent, but
you place embodiment front and center.
Or the front, and they left
this.
Area right around here.
So something like.
A seven to
but then you're like.
Wait a second,
that's not too many steps removed
from where the ears first pipe them.
So the idea that something like,
you know, going from.
Phonemes or you know.
From sound patterns
undifferentiated to phonemes and.
It's the steps.
It ends up making cortex its functions,
in my opinion, a lot more applicable.
It becomes somewhat like location,
location, location and location
relative to the modalities
that ends up explaining a lot of things.
That similar story for Broca's area.
What a.
Coincidence that it's not a hop skip
and a jump away from.
What might move your mouth. That's
there's devil's.
In details here.
I don't to be glib
and underestimate the complexity.
But the.
Claim is that actually once
you place embodiment in the center,
an elegance kind of falls out and becomes
a lot easier to keep track of things.
If you're thinking of cortex as this
control cybernetic control hierarchy
over to basically help a body move
through the world
and model
the world as it moves through it.
So we are ready,
I think, to get to free will
and so taking these model frame sequences
and here is doing one
for this experience of standing.
In. To make tea.
And then taking that model.
And then porting, it's
all about experience.
So what was all about paradigm?
So some people say today,
some people say, look back.
I think look that said, look at.
But I will. Continue to say.
What they more common and I just will
that is that you're there and.
You want to see do people
or don't they have something like
meaningful
conscious control over their actions.
And so the idea is, OK, let's
strip this down and take like the most
insignificant of all actions, like, well,
surely we need to have control.
There.
If we're gonna say
we have control anymore.
And so the decision to just move
your hand
based on feeling like you want to do so
and this coming from basically it's
endogenous.
You're not being something
decided from without, but
you do something
based on something internal to you.
And what was found with these.
Studies or Bay,
is that you get this ramping activity
preceding.
The. Decision to move your hand.
One. Of these, OK,
you have this clock, right?
And there is it's a big clock
that you're looking at. And.
That might be a or a big hand
moving in a circle
and the reason you have
this is basically so that you can
estimate the time when it was that
you said, I will move my hand.
When did you decide
and you then say, OK, when you made that
decision, what were you looking at?
Where was this dot
as it moved around in a circle?
And this can get you very fine
resolution subset and resolution,
because if it's a big clock, it's
because then the DOT will be moving
slowly and you say, OK, right there.
But what's.
Observed is that you're getting this
ramping activity, which is predictive.
Of. The action called the readiness
potential.
And it will peak, you know.
A good 200 milliseconds
before you reporting.
It varies, but it'll peak substantially
before you saying, I've decided.
And so if.
And so the claim is, well,
if this potential as predictive
information of your action
and is the cause of your action
and it's happening prior
to your conscious
decision, your decision cannot be
the thing that caused the.
Action
there's a.
There's a problem right away
with this in that with your methods,
you're actually averaging over many,
many trials
to get these waveforms because you're
measuring from the outside of the brain.
It's like trying to detect like events
inside a stadium while measuring
like listening to the roar of the crowd
on the outside and you're
limiting what you can do.
So you have to average together
a lot of different episodes
and then you get these event
related potentials or ERPs. And
so you.
Get predictive information
from this of when people moved.
But the idea that a readiness
potential is causal or deterministic
in some fashion,
there's some debate about that.
Whether you can infer that.
I'm. Going to say
that the readiness potential is
in fact reflecting a causal process
and it's reflecting a conscious
causal process
even that is contributing to the action.
Upstream of.
The decision itself,
where the decision could have some.
More.
You know, it depends and I don't know
if there's one account, but it could have
some phenomenal aspects to it
in that the decision
is not necessarily the thing.
It's not the only difference maker there.
But the idea is that this.
Is a function.
Of mental imagery where you.
Are imagining will.
When you're.
Rehearsing moving your hand,
you're having different friends
associated with it.
And that building up.
Of that recurrent building up of activity
in these body maps,
whether we're talking about.
The getting.
Ready to actually change your purpose
of this pose as you're imagining
starting to move closer to a threshold
where you're going to get robust
enough activity that is actually going
to drive your muscles and your effector.
Systems or.
Building with activity
in your intercept of no doubt,
it seems like you're insular and singular
hierarchies and maybe they're crossed,
maybe they're synesthetic like
cross couplings with other modalities
that that building up
of a feeling of urge is itself
consciousness leading to the stream.
The causal stream of action.
So that I.
Would say so, yeah.
The and then on top of all the different
imaginings would be orchestrated by
the temple system
would be the basic model. So
currently and.
So and
so currently I am working on
expanding this to sing
with different states of consciousness.
And. The ways
in which they could impact these sorts
of phenomena.
In terms
of changing your awareness
of this rehearsal process
or changing
that would be one of the primary
things of interest.
So and also whether differences
in the mechanisms of agency
could potentially contribute
to the phenomenology of psychedelics.
I'll try to explain what I mean.
So here would be someone relatively
unaltered engaging in mental rehearsal.
Your mind's
sort of wandering off to nature.
They're seeing a tree.
Here's imagination, here's perception
here more vivid than imagination.
And they're just sort of imagining
things, imagining will I move on to move?
And then in a certain point,
the imagination becomes vivid enough.
That they. Can really see it happening.
And at a certain point. Of.
Vividness of a map,
things as a function of this rehearsal.
Of Will I move on, I move, you get enough
build up of.
Whether we're on the implementation
level, we might talk
or mechanistic level,
we might talk about recurrent activity
in terms of active inference.
On the functional level,
we might talk about model.
Evidence but.
At a certain point you cross a certain
threshold leading to model selection
of you altering your purpose at the pose,
and this becoming
a self-fulfilling prophecy
through act of inference.
You then minimize the prediction error
between your imagination, a moving
and the and the action
through reflex arcs the way that.
Basically.
Motor control is thought or
is thought to work in act of inference.
And predictive processing.
So the psychedelic angle would be as
someone was dosing with these compounds,
their imagination becomes more.
Vivid.
And they might show stronger
ramping at first.
And maybe greater awareness
of the patterns of mental stimulation
leading up to the action.
It might get stronger
still as you dose more.
And more
and also.
Greater coupling between and tear
receptive and proper receptive.
O'Dowd is increasing the gain
on this positive feedback
between mental imagery
and feelings of urge.
And so in a way,
this would be an enhancement.
Of willing.
The willing aspect of agency
as you move up the dose response curve.
But then you get to a certain level
and you start to go
into this psychedelic regime
where your thought becomes
highly creative and then you're directed
willing to start to.
Go down.
Potentially. The idea is you might.
Find.
Other things competing
for your awareness, different creative
possibilities.
So you're
now imagining nature very vividly.
And this is competing with you
rehearsing, Will I move or won't I move?
And in
and let's again.
Predicting I'm.
About to move up with the dance.
This is in first is
the new You erecting a
move might become lots.
And lots of extremely high doses
you might get and compromise
of these mechanisms of agency
of this conjoining of your intercepted
and your receptive predictions
of your basically
of your stream of consciousness
being pulled.
Along.
By value driven policies selection via
sophisticated effect of inference.
So I think so.
The reverse direction is this in terms of
this paradigm,
potentially informing psychedelics
could be the one source of hallucinations
or delusions or atypical.
Altered.
Consciousness and cognition would be
that if you take the basic mechanism,
micro mechanics of agency. And.
And you compromise that.
So, you know, as you're
you're beginning to somewhat
imagine action, but it's not
well integrated
into some causal unfolding,
you could come to this
anomalous inferences.
About what's. Causing these basically.
The different.
Endogenous activity,
your brain, the different.
Events.
That could lead to motor to motor actions
if these aren't being integrated
into a self-consistent coherent
causal unfolding.
One of the ways
that you could try to make sense of this
would be a confabulation
of something like a hallucination and
so this could potentially also explain
some of psychedelic phenomenology.
And. Potentially.
A clinical.
Neuropsychiatric terminology
with things like schizophrenia
as potentially being a function
of disrupted agency mechanisms.
So that's currently the area of focus.
And there's going to be a preprint
just came.
Out on that called.
On the degrees of freedom worth
having psychedelics
as a window for understanding
and expanding.
Of free will.
I believe that's what I called it.
And so that would be a little bit.
Also of
apologies
if there's any strange stream hiccups,
but could you maybe unpack what
the alien or extraterrestrial was doing?
And how does the confabulation relate
to a narrative
understanding of action.
So. In this one,
so we're showing out
just like imagining your hand moving
or imagining being a nature
and then Sam Harris.
Just goes up.
And it goes up
and you might start to get some more
intense intercepted sensation sensations.
The. Five H-2A receptors,
which heavily mediate
the effects of classic psychedelics.
There.
They're highly expressed in the interior.
And so the top
of the intercept of hierarchy.
And so keep going up
comes the sensations become more intense.
Imagination moves closer to reality.
And so here. Like what.
I'm calling the heroic dose
in this extreme dose regimes,
you're starting to get, for instance,
like your ownership of the actions
are starting to get undermined.
So here I'm depicting
like you find your hand moving,
but you're not accounting
for you're willing of the move
being the thing you're not saying, Oh,
I was rehearsing it and it felt this way.
And that was part of the causal feeling
to action.
You just found yourself moving.
And so one way you could make sense
of this or confabulate around
this here is a hand
like it's a feeling of the hand
pushing down on your hand
from without just an example of
a potential confabulation
or hallucination someone might have.
And this one here, it's expanded
and it's this basically
someone it's not even your hand anymore
pressing it, but an alien pressing.
It's just an example, for instance,
so psychedelics,
they the classic psychedelics
will act in these five H2O receptors.
They are heavily expressed on these deep
pyramidal neurons. Of.
Texas.
Six layers
the layer five will basically they're
big neurons that loop with the thalamus
and they let you form these broad
synchronous complexes,
which in predictive processing
are thought to encode your beliefs,
some subset of
which would be your experience.
And so if you increase the gain
on these, the ideas that you might have
enhanced perceptual vividness,
but because you've
done a radical alteration to
multiple
kinds tudes like the normal regime. Of.
Processing in your mind,
the normal ways you would model,
even though you're experiencing things
intensely,
this would actually be
of an atypical variety of experience.
And so here is the intense experience
and the intense perception
apperception of the alien.
It's a counterfactual alien.
It's not actually an alien, but
that would that would be an example
of an anomalous inference you might make.
And it has. Some.
Relation to what's happening
and the fact that maybe
there was some motor rehearsal going on,
but you're not able to keep track of it.
And so and here this is
you're actually having phenomenal
consciousness in each of these moments,
but you don't have conscious access
unless in these iterative
moments of experience,
you can somehow get callbacks.
Where.
Things can be contextualized
within some sort of causal unfolding.
The claim would be that basically
this would be a way of separating
out phenomenal consciousness
from conscious access,
that there's things that can happen
as you're generating these Quayle states,
as estimates of what's
happening of system, world,
system, world, system, world
specifically your sensorium
as you think it is
based on your current engagement
or in counterfactual circumstances,
and that that's
a stream of consciousness,
but that not all of the frames
of experience.
Are. Accessible or memorable.
And so in this case here, you know,
maybe there was some rehearsal,
but you're not keeping track of it.
And then the, the, the.
The, the best causal account
you're able to come. Up with.
Was that an alien made you do it.
And you might have even forgotten
that this was you,
or maybe you do remember it,
but would need probably
some more contextualization or not.
It's unclear, but.
So that would be the basic ideas
that psychedelics
would be increasing consciousness level
or the vividness of your.
Experience.
But potentially undermining the coherence
in terms of causal unfolding
or your usual priors
by which you structure the world.
In the spirit of Robin Harris and Carl
Fishman's rebus model, which I'm
currently discussing in the context
of a broader framework that I call Alvis.
But yeah, that help it all are.
Like an alias. Like, yeah.
It also it reminded me of what you said
about the different levels
and their interdependence
and mutual constraints.
So it's like a sound is heard
and potentially
in one state of consciousness
or mind your brain,
it's 98% likely to be one thing
and option B and C are 1% likelihood.
And so just goes forward with
as if option A like as if I'm in control.
But then some things might happen
where like that
1% chance that it is an alien
gets accepted and sort of passed forward.
And then that might lead
to the experience
through the generative
model of something that like
was a distribution.
Also, it's like a change
in quantitative distributions
that leads to a qualitative change
and increasingly higher and categorical
and semantic experiential
layers
beautifully. So
and it.
Would depend on your cultural priors.
So and whether we would call this
like a relaxed belief or a strength
in belief, I'm not sure.
But. You know, for instance,
you might not be singing like if you.
Were an.
Indigenous people of South America,
for instance,
in know they might not see an alien.
It might be related to something
having to do with their spirituality
and their whatever available myths
you have.
Would.
Then go into basically this
interpretation, your best guess.
Which.
Is always wrong, sometimes useful,
but your best guess of what's going on
will be different depending on
what they would call the
to set in the setting but also where
the setting is the broader cultural
the and setting are also broader
to the culture.
Not everyone will be.
Not ever will come
to the inference of aliens probably.
And actually that's that's been shown
that hallucinations
are culturally specific
yeah.
With which kinds of extraterrestrial
morphologies are seen in relationship
to which are prevalent in the media
and the stories of a given region.
I don't know all the details
but one can imagine.
Not everyone
I mean, like you could like say like.
A maybe there.
Is something about like gray aliens
which is like a little more archetypal.
I don't if I'd say this, but like.
If. You like the Eigen Dimension,
so like morphological variation
what's relevant to us?
Like, you're just like exaggerating
many of the dimensions
that would be relevant for us, engaging
in intersubjective modeling.
Or. Modeling of ourselves.
Even for the sake of control.
So like hands
like bigger hands might be important,
whereas like attentional
inference
like where is this person tending to?
Where am I tending to?
So you don't want to know
the heads in the eyes.
That's going to be really crucial.
And that's a far out story. But
you know, there.
Could be aspects.
Of that
that. Aren't just through the medium.
But it's and it's.
Super interesting and yeah,
not, not to go into alien stream mode,
but thinking about a large headed
archetype with very large
dark eyes and the long fingers
like you're kind of hinting at,
it's like it's all pupil,
it's all cortex it's
it doesn't have the strength,
but it has a lot of nimbleness
with its hands and with its body.
And so like that's like one archetype
of, of cognitive action
I don't know.
And then what?
Maybe there's a blob and a shadow.
There's like these different archetypes,
different little characters
in this comic book of cognition.
Not that.
Different from a child's affordances
soon like, they're not
they're not capable of, like,
moving things around much, but it's like
their intentional actions are mostly like
hand-eye coordination. Of.
Like, that's their purchase on the world.
That's their grip.
For all that's.
So this is the current like, OK,
this is how might psychedelics
inform our understanding
of the micro mechanics of agency
and how might the micro mechanics
of agency
inform our understanding
of what psychedelics do?
And that's currently one of the things
I'm focusing on and.
About to.
Do some experiments on at the Center for
Psychedelic and Consciousness Science.
I'm working. Out
at Hopkins, but the
fundamentally.
Upstream of this,
the idea is that these studies
which purportedly show
that there is no free will,
they show no such thing, it's
very ambiguous what they're showing.
And I believe if you do an active
inferential handling of them,
you'll actually see that there are
several ways in which consciousness
is contributing to causal streams
leading to action,
which would be having some of
the varieties of free will worth having.
You know,
is it arbitrary degrees of free will? No.
There's some varieties of free
will worth having that we don't have.
Like, can you just like fly
all of a sudden?
They'll be nice, will be worthwhile.
We can't do that either.
But if.
You want your beliefs and desires
to be able to
meaningfully side
to be be able to be said to be.
Meaningful.
Efficient core screenings, maybe even
maximally efficient course screenings.
Of. What is happening,
I think we do have that.
And I think you can find this even within
these Lubet paradigms. Of.
If you didn't
I think you still have many
of the varieties of free
will worth having because many people
have criticized saying like,
oh, just moving your hand
without a reason.
That's not really agency
that's not what we want from free will.
We want like meaningful decisions
sure.
But I think even though even though
for these even for these studies.
Which people often will.
Trot out and saying, look,
my brain made me do it, even then,
I don't think it follows.
That.
They show that we
that our consciousness is ever phenomenal
through and through.
And I think active instance basically
shows some of the particular ways
that consciousness is indeed causal
even in these circumstances.
And I think that's a very big deal.
I don't know how
well it's surviving the replication
crisis, but,
you know, there's plenty of studies.
Showing that.
Some undesirable consequences of people
not believing in their own free
will or their own agency
whether or not that works,
that I think there is a kind. Of.
This face value kind of this and that
like kind of like Dumbo's magic feather.
It's like this elephant.
That.
I'm taking this from Dan Dennett
from his book Freedom of Owls.
But this.
Has a feather that the crows told them
will help him fly
and get his big ears
and using the fly when he had the feather
boas because he believes.
Whether or not.
Believing in free
will gives you free will, not believing
you're a meaningful cause,
that becomes true just by believing. It.
So, you know,
I think it's it's quite dangerous
to take basically
something
where we have something precious,
something that basically will empower us
to pursue our values
and to say based on the seven studies
and using the authority of science,
telling people.
That.
They are not meaningful causes,
I think that's extremely pernicious.
And I
think act of inference can
there's already great work being done,
like within like neuro philosophy of free
will pushing back against this.
And I think active inference can help
showing people
what are the meaningful
degrees of freedom that they have
and how can they be preserved
and expanded.
While very interesting,
do you have any more slides
to go through or
may I ask some questions?
No more slides
about it.
OK, so
those who are watching live,
please feel free to ask a question.
Otherwise,
I want to pick up near the beginning
when you spoke about finding oneself
in a stream of action.
So what is happening when we find
ourselves in a stream of action
and I want to hear what you have to say
and then take this to some questions
about memory and free will,
but when we are suddenly aware,
like, well, I'm on a run, I mean,
I guess I did make prior decisions
about deciding and so on, but like,
whoa, now my leg is moving forward.
So the
I imagine is this varies
a good amount like as a.
And in.
Per an intra individual
difference variable.
So like both between
and within people, you're going at a
good amount of variance on this I think.
But the way Heidegger described.
It in terms. Of this difference between.
Describing like hammering and you know.
When you're a skilled craftsperson, it's
the hammer is in your hand
and it is ready at hand and you're
you could, your mind could be elsewhere
or people might have the phenomenology
of this like on a run or on a drive.
You might just find yourself home.
You can listen to an audiobook
you'll barely know.
You're just you have this effortless
mastery of the task set,
and it's only when something goes wrong
that things are brought into awareness.
And so the
own only.
And so then you get this motion between
so here's the hammer just in your hand
ready at hand to present to hand.
And now it's in the foreground.
It was initially in the unconscious
or semi-conscious background.
And so like if someone's running
like for instance, they could largely be
in a similar state of effortless mastery,
especially because you just
natural pendulums motion gets you
like a lot of the control that combined
with some spinal pattern generators,
you know, it's a little other tweaks.
It's like you barely need to do anything
once you once you've been trained up.
But let's say you're trail running
and or let's say you run
and then you step on something
the idea would be
that this violation of your expectations
would cause basically prediction error
and that this prediction error,
the thing was different.
So OK, so within predictive
process and part of what is.
Like.
Here in phenomenology
where things just become unconscious.
And. You only become conscious
when you're something's wrong,
you might well being careful
not to conflate levels of analysis,
you could get a good amount of this
just from
predictive processing
with a dual tier architecture.
Like if basically you're really well
trained up,
you can explain things
or you can basically handle things
just with these efficient unconscious
couplings, unconscious inference,
as in a bunch of reflex arcs
being skillfully deployed,
doing most of the things you need to do,
whether you want to call this modeling
or not, as a matter of choice,
I would call it modeling, but
you wouldn't need to become aware of it
unless something was wrong.
And so then the idea is this lower
down, it's not handle.
You don't predict
if you don't explain away
the prediction error it makes its way.
Deeper into the brain, into the
it becomes more broadly.
The deeper point is, of course, it's
more lucid.
Modeling and conscious.
Modeling
of the.
Processing.
Tools.
Which will be greater, more capable
of accessing these richly connected sub
networks, which could support basically
this larger scale
integrative simulation, some aspect of
which would be your experience.
I don't know if that got it wrong at all,
but yeah.
Awesome.
So we're we're driving back towards
freewill because I really liked
how you approached it
in, in this conversation.
So I want to think about three concepts
memory,
freewill and experience.
What are their Venn diagrams like?
Can we of things that we remember, did
we have free will for them
or not more or less than expected
for things that we experience?
Do we remember them more or not?
Could there be something
that you didn't experience
but you remember and had a free will on
and so on, like how our memory free will,
an experience bound together
oh. I mean, that's a fantastic question.
I don't.
So what's coming to mind?
That's that,
that's a whole other conversation no.
What was coming
line for me at the moment.
As that.
There's a partial definitional
aspect of a connection between
free will and experience in that
what people
so people want different things
I wouldn't call free will.
One thing
in fact, I actually think there's
a certain wisdom and just like
the language of it, like people want both
like the willing they want the agency
and they want the degrees of freedom in
terms of they want to be able to pivot.
They want to be able. To.
Have what they do
be a function of their past
and being constrained by their memories
and their meanings from the past.
But they also want to be able to break
free, whether in the face of something
new or just encountering
something new or to explore.
And so
having that the freedom for exploration
is all going to be a part of agency,
both within a context and across time.
But the memory is going to be important
because without the memory,
that's the constraint based on values,
based on you.
You. Know, there's many
aspects of the self, for instance,
some of some of the most essential ones
and maybe some of the
the gold standards of free will,
some Frankfurt mesh theory affairs.
But it's like this interface of like
you both want things and you want that.
You want them
where the wanting that you want
is based on this integrative
and like narrative type self.
And so there would be a way
in which memory with very strongly
we're free will would be a function
both of experience that you want
your experience, your consciousness
and your experience to be part
of the causal stream leading to action,
part of your valuing
your affective inference.
You want that to be influencing
both across time and in the moment
and so
the experience would be essential
like that.
It's not clear
the many identities argued like that.
The free.
Will and consciousness
must always be handled together.
But without memory.
You also, though it's not you either.
I think there's an interesting thing
though, in terms of like you're you're
alluding to like basically connections
between causation and memory.
And I believe we are better capable
of remembering things
when we can take them up into a causal
unfolding
this gives this basically affords
a representation with a more
of a sparse structure of, of salience
of this led to this, led to this.
And then you hold that causal graph
in your mind and as basically the core
of your generative model.
And it seems to be like a highly
efficient way of remembering things.
It's come up
with a causal account of them
and so if something is a product
of your agency in a way that's
that is automatically structuring things
in this causal fashion.
And so there should be a connection
between having agency and free
will in a circumstance
and being better able to remember things.
I don't know if that's the case,
but it seems like something
from education theory suggests
like with respect to act of learning.
But I can see that
going a lot of different ways. But
and so that that's a deep question.
And those that's, that's
what came to mind.
But like what do you think?
Wow. Well,
the last piece you brought up about the
the Spa City kind of the sharpness
on the spa city of the causal story
and then things that have a sharp
and a sparse causal architecture
as experienced with our very limited
working memory.
They're like predigested
and therefore very apt
to be able to
leave certain kinds of traces.
And then maybe something
could leave a trace that didn't have
a perceived sparse
causal architecture in the moment.
But that might be like
an example of a memory that's hard
to recall or that might be like
cleaned up in post-production
and may be very susceptible
to being influenced
because, like, subsequent updates could
try to
draw attention
to part of that uncertainty and like
if there was just a loose memory
of many things happening at a scene,
asking even a question about part of it
could start to sharpen that aspect.
And so it's
it's an interesting question.
And also kind of like the questions like
what if you had some sort of suffering
but you didn't remember it
or in between moments
or when you were sleeping,
you were having some sort
of negative experience
so just
I mean, what is happening
with the mind in the brain?
The the brain seems to be continuous.
But then we have these more flashes
and discrete ness
and shifting of mental attention.
But they just.
Weren't good.
I just like.
The way you're describing. This. Some of
I feel like it's like you
feel like a really good case in point of
like the answer to do or don't we have
free will should always be.
What do you mean?
And the answer is always. Like like.
Like you're like the way like
you're saying these different processes
can either go together
synergistically or come apart.
It's like how many meaningful
degrees of freedom do we have
and what circumstances or
and what senses do we have?
How much of which of the
varieties of free will
that we want in different circumstances
so it's like the answer is
there, isn't there free will?
It seems like like much more interesting
is getting into the details
and useful is like
getting into the details
you're talking about right now
with like the different ways
that memory and experience and choice
can all go together
or not,
both within and across time like that's.
And then that.
Answer is like,
I guess you could say that's like
that's the real problem of free will.
And then that that
interesting.
Yeah.
Like when the experiment of pushing
the button is presented
as being about the exertion of decision
making in the moment,
rather than the memory
or the recalling of something
that might have been different
in the moments,
those are quite different settings
and it could be
a total different neurophysiology.
So and also what you said about how
this sort of tension
between having a connection to the past
and the constraints that it provides,
but also the ability to choose,
and I guess that's what's explored
in these varieties papers.
So I wanted to not just ask
like what are the varieties,
but just specifically asking
about the similarities
and differences with bodily action.
What are the varieties of free will
we might have with respect to bodily
action, like the so-called voluntary
and involuntary bodily processes
and then mental action
where in active inference
we can model regimes of attention
and metacognition
and thought as like action
policies on mental states.
So what kinds of free will
are out there for the body?
And what
does that say about what might be
a cognitive degree of freedom or not?
Like,
you know, just choosing what we want.
So in terms of like body.
Actions
if we're dealing with something
highly rehearsed.
Then it.
Seems like
that could be an example.
Or or something where it's like
I think the nail on the bottle.
That the predictive processing
hammers strike and the loop is closed
before it ever even enters the. Brain.
It's in the, the.
The CNS and the reflex arc
but doesn't even make it up top.
Where your body. Moves.
That's just after the fact
that you're aware of it.
But then if you're doing something like.
And so.
Then like at this other
extreme of abstraction,
you might have something like planning.
Reaching a.
Distal
goal where there's many steps involve
and you need to come to
some sort of sequence of the steps.
And along the way, I know
it's a bit extreme, but they'll be.
Like.
There's certain things
that have to happen somewhere.
So like at the extreme of abstraction,
it might be something like
going to grad school
or something like that or, you know.
To getting a new job to how it's.
Like that is
so there's a lot of things that happen
have happened before, other things
and a lot of dependencies
and a lot of multiple relies ability
there's always multiple route
realize ability.
Like I go to reach for this glass
I could have reached for like this.
I could have done a weird thing
and gone. Like this.
Or like,
you know, I could have pinky out Pinky
and, you know, prefer Pinky out.
But like there's all sorts of things
that could have done
there is mostly realizable,
but the multiple realize ability
of something like,
you know, going to college
going to grad school, that's even more
so like the number of ways
you can go into it.
And then I guess I'm thinking
like in this middle regime of something
that's still like very clearly metric
but would be novel and like fine grained
motor control, like I'm learning
for the first time,
like I'm doing a tea ceremony.
Or I'm learning of.
Calligraphy or I'm just learning to knit
or something like.
There.
It's the. Fine grained. Things are now.
Being monitored as present at hand.
And you actually need to use
your sophisticated inference machinery
to help scaffold this.
Basically,
the acquisition. Of.
Skilled motor abilities of skill,
the capacity
for skill, motor performance,
but I would also, I think, suggest that.
The. Whole way through, it's always built
experience, one when once it's being
co-opted or controlled and in its control
ability is always modal
in a mature fashion.
So one of the claims
I make in this paper.
It turns out
that it's called.
Pre motor theory,
but that basically like.
Through.
Partial expression of a motor command
or a motor prediction,
the utterance
copy from that the associated sensations
can be used as a means of top down
intentional selection could be used
as a means of attending to memory.
In terms of working
memory, basically you can use these
partially expressed
motor predictions,
not enough to actually cross threshold,
but use them to basically
as a source of control over dynamics.
Of where.
Your awareness is going and
what's going in or out of your awareness.
And the claim I make
is actually that this is an exhaustive
like this is the only like lever
you have is basically whatever
is built off of a control hierarchy,
off of skeletal muscle.
It's a claim.
But the idea would be like even a table,
something as abstract as,
you know, going to college
or grad school,
there's still going to be
some has to cash out a certain.
Amount of modal.
You're seeing yourself
in the different contexts,
even for the abstracts,
like the mouth, like justice,
you still to experience
it, it's still going to have
some sort of thing that you know,
your hand shares justices scales.
Here's
the courtroom, here's seeing this memory
from your past where there is an officer
justice was served.
Here is you feeling this like uneasiness
or this like righteousness.
So and so the idea I.
Would claim is that like
any kind of control on any level
will always cow shout metrically.
But there are meaningful differences
in terms of
whether you're engaging with something
which is involving these immediate
fast feedback loops and might be multiple
realizable but less so. Or.
Something which. The.
Affordance
structure is more being played out
in terms of your capacity to control
and relate to it in terms of these
even more multiple realizable high level
plans of all the things
situations you might be,
and they'll be related to achieving.
High level.
Goals or abstract.
Goals
I don't know if that makes sense.
11 thought on
that is it's like a jigsaw puzzle.
So there's only one way to assemble it.
And it's kind of like there's
therefore this bundle of trajectories
of different realizations
of how one is going to assemble it
like there's
sort of what happens on the table,
all the combinatorics
of the way to assemble it.
And then there's like all of the real
life combinatorics about how many minutes
am I going to spend playing this jigsaw
and then I'm going to go
get up and do other stuff.
And so the multiple
realization of the jigsaw where it does
all kind of come back to being completed
is one thing.
And then yeah,
you brought up how when things are even,
the outcomes are unknown
or there's multiple realizations.
Those are where we start to maybe
think about hierarchical
nesting of models like
we've been discussing in the slam paper
and also the vivid imagining
of different future states.
What is the regime
of attention that might
for somebody who wants to be an athlete,
help them make practicing
and being on that path like more natural?
So what how specific and what modalities
that's kind of what it made me think of.
But I, I kind of want to keep on going on
this mental action route.
Has there been anything like a mental
or a cognitive leap experiment,
like where the instructions would be like
take a couple of breaths
and just,
you know, get up and walk around
or whatever, just take a couple breaths
and then identify
the moment on the clock.
When you chose to think about X
a pure mental on mental assessment.
So I had the.
Surface.
I just before I forget, I actually think
like what you just mentioned,
like the optimal attentional engagement
or something like motor
or something like like a sport
or some performance actually.
And that's like a key example
of like through skilled mental action
or not through the skill fulness
of your mental actions,
having more or less freedom
where like for instance,
if you're
choking, for instance, you do it wrong.
Jun. Tani has a good paper on choking,
an act of inference.
And so if you get that wrong,
they'll be like your free will
being undermined by your mental action.
Not being well.
Calibrated in terms
of where you're positioning
your attentional selection for optimal.
Grip or.
Optimal engagement
with what you're doing.
The. In terms of this
purely more purely mental action.
Lebed And. There's a couple.
There's different.
Versions of it that have been run.
Some of. Which I think.
Would get a little bit.
More to that.
And. Kind of what you describe
in terms of
remote mouse has one paper or called them
decisions
like deciding or decisions that matter.
And so basically
it would be choosing between charities.
And so then you
add in this
charity choice, you actually don't see
this same type of ramping.
And I think this supports to some degree.
The model.
I'm suggesting and that like
if this ramping is a build up
of basically activity
and your action oriented body maps
cross coupling
with your intercept of body maps,
I mean, this feeling of urge
and mental stimulation, it makes sense.
It would have felt something
like pressing a button.
But if it's something like which charity
I'm going to donate to,
you might not get
that same kind of take up in feedback.
And so I think that's some evidence
in support of that.
But I think the particular thing
you brought up, there's this
and this is a direction. I'm.
Looking in beginning to look into.
There's these closely related
wave forms to the readiness potential,
the event related negativity and the.
Spin.
Stimulus preceding negativity.
And I believe so
some of them would be, for instance.
Preparing for.
Information that's coming.
And. Then acting.
I think that would be the earring or
the speech and the stimulus proceedings.
It is
you're preparing to receive information.
That's.
Possibly salient,
but there's no action required.
So I think that might be potentially you
could think of all these things, though,
and actively as having they look
very similar electrophysiological
and I would suggest that they are
all fundamentally similar and that what
they're using, whether we're talking.
About.
Patterns of attentional selection
or specifically
orchestrating mental stimulation to.
Act. Or not in terms of an overt action,
then all these cases,
it is grounded in the modalities
and this is basically understood
implementation as recurrent activity
and different places of control
hierarchy over body maps.
Or in terms of.
Algorithmically and functionally
an accumulation of model evidence
for shifting your practice of the pose
now before an overt action.
If we're talking mental action,
similar story, but if partially, but. If
you're if.
The model evidence I guess
would be a slightly different model, but.
It's if.
What you're imagining is
your own, you're imagining
your body being in a different state
that would allow you to orient
differently
to bias your sensors differently,
to move your attention
around differently,
to do different precision weighting.
But you don't imagine it vividly enough
that it will actually drive
your spinal reflex arcs and that
but that this would be
what you would use
even for potential purely mental acts,
it would still be coopting a control
hierarchy off of skeletal muscle.
And the reason I focus on skeletal muscle
is because it's designed
to have basically large gross actions
with low latency and this controllable.
And. The conditions for find
great control are realized
because you can actually direct your
sensors using your effectors
with a large scale meaningful outcome
that can be causally modeled
and tracked and controlled.
And so then the idea is that basically.
So. Vygotsky first expressed an idea
like this, I think with respect,
he thought as inner speech,
where first you learn how to speak
and then through partially expressing
your speech,
you learn how to co-opt this process
for a stream of thought
as inner speech.
And then whether you want to say that
that exhaust thinking is another thing,
but inner speech would be part
of a significant part of thinking.
But so the idea is
this is all intentional mental
operations, whether we're talking
about shifting around
basically the the fine green
adjustments of an overt skilled motor act
or guiding your mental action
with respect to attention
and mental imagery
and imaginings that in each case.
You have the.
Initial affordances structure,
the initial control levers
established via these overt we express
behaviors and couplings of world,
which then later, by partially expressing
them, gives you something
you can repurpose for things
like imaginative planning.
Or. Covert attention,
or I would argue, any intentionally
influence mental process,
maybe ultimately
have its origins in this co-opting.
Of motor control hmm.
All claim.
OK, so what could be systems?
Yes, go ahead.
I just it could be wrong.
Not financial advice,
not not extraterrestrial advice,
hardly even active advice.
It's very interesting.
What systems
rise to this capacity
and does their embodiments matter?
So like there are insects
with tremendously reduced
central nervous systems.
One could imagine a computational system
that can engage in counterfactuals,
but it's only affordance
or embodiment is like one,
you know, Morse code
receiver or something like that.
So what systems
have this capacity and why.
So I.
Definitely don't know the boundaries,
but if I were to shoot
from the hip on this, the idea would be
the handling would still be of this
computational neuro phenomenology
or marrying the phenomenology.
But instead of drawing brains, we would
drive a different nervous system.
Or whatever the.
Signaling information
processing system is.
We would still give it
this kind of handling
where there would be a mechanism,
there would be a function,
there would be some intermediate
algorithmic mapping across these levels.
And then you connect this
to phenomenology.
And so if in this phenomenology
you're having basically gold states
being represented and these and the
representation of these Gulf states.
Is part is.
At that level,
you're also able to get an account
of the guidance of action selection
to bring them about
then you could say that
you have degrees of freedom.
In that way.
So if we're talking about something
like an insects, the.
You. Actually
send me a really interesting paper
recently about dual systems
thinking broadly construed
including for insects.
Where and this.
It seems like you would need
at least a
a two tier
hierarchy where this upper level.
Can break.
Free of immediate engagements
with this consortium and where.
This lower level would allow.
For your couplings with the world
and the orchestration of overt action
selection in terms of actually
like sensory motor coupling to the world
and then a process which can basically
on top of that hierarchically higher.
That could.
Infer these transitions,
but without them being expressed.
And if you have that, then you could do
the types of counterfactual processing
that you would need for planning
and constructing causal models.
It seems possible
that insects might be able to do this
in terms of, for instance,
like in the paper you sent recently.
Like these like do this.
So the central complex
has a lot of these properties
of the hippocampal system.
It's kind of like a hushpuppies,
the hippocampal system
and the thalamus
at the same time.
But and it's giving
you like the salience. Map
used. For both orienting and.
Moving but then.
You also get these mushroom bodies,
which are like the stratum,
which would be basically helping
with that moment to moment
action selection,
biasing it in a value driven direction.
And so in this paper,
you're getting like this. Some
dual.
Dual systems for control, one
which seems to be more immediate
and reactive, and the other
seems to be governed by slower processes
and so it's possible
that something like this
so so that it's possible
that this could give you
the ability to do.
Sweeps of.
Possibilities of counterfactual inference
where you basically take
the beginning
of expressing the motor command.
And so the insects thinking
I'm going to locomote in that direction.
I don't know the evidence
well enough to know if this is the case.
But it could be and then
so so.
For a robot like a rodent,
you'll see these sweeps
in the hippocampus of like there's a maze
and you'll see like.
Predictors of whether most schools.
Left or right
you'll see these place fields
representing different points in space.
And then in anticipation of this, you'll
see these sweeps ahead of activity.
And then where the sweep is most robust,
that will be the branch that
the animal will go down, will go down.
That's the places in theory, you could do
a similar thing by other means,
maybe with some homology,
even in the insect nervous system,
maybe you can even do it in an ant colony
if you're getting into a trap
where capable of aggregating across
all these different
finer grained couplings
and engaging in control.
But so basically, whatever has.
Already.
I can't say I'm not going to say
sufficient.
The claim I'll make for necessity
would be some sort of
dual tier architecture
where the lower level
gives you the problems with the world
and the upper level.
Gives you.
Counterfactual,
affordance and integration.
Across.
These lower level, potentially segregated
coupling processes.
Something like that could do it for you.
And so could insects do it now?
Potentially, I don't know.
Could the insect colony do it?
Maybe the thing.
Where I would place
a potential constraint. Is.
It seems like we might need
an architecture
to have properties
where it could signal fast enough
where these inferences of quickly enough
that it can stay on top of its evolving
action perception cycles.
So in terms of its surfing uncertainty,
it's moving into the world as couplings,
the architecture,
whether we're talking about a brain
or some set of signaling across
multiple individuals and like a hive mind
we want it to be fast enough
to how the estimates correspond
to this first graph.
What Benji would call
I think in the control factors of the.
World and
it in.
A. Causal world.
Model where you are an agent within
it seems like you would need to have
the ability to model
independently control the factors.
And so you need to signal
a signaling system that's fast enough
to pull this off.
And so some sort of small world
network architecture
would be likely required
where you have a combination. Of.
Local modularity but then synergy
through having some central hub.
And so if this could be pulled off
by the hive mind
and if this can orchestrate
the overall swarm to do things quickly
enough to basically have purchase,
have the right grips on the world
that it can both inform and be informed
by its action perception cycles,
then you could have an agency
architecture,
which by some dimensions
we might describe in terms of free will.
That dodge the question.
Of why respond?
What about just the computational one?
What if it was a computational one
and it was it was instantiating
a digital twin,
a limited or comprehensive digital
twin of itself.
Yeah.
I mean, I personally think. The.
Like like an integral information
theorist would say absolutely not.
Some people
within like active inference
communities would say, no,
it has to be physically realized.
But I think something like a digital twin
or some sort of emulation,
the important thing for me is.
That the.
There is a set of dependencies. Of.
Effective connectivity
that could be involving virtual processes
and that if you trace out the patterns
of effective connectivity, of.
Kinds.
Not necessarily physical,
then necessarily like made of matter.
That.
If that is
entailing the modeling of a system
and its relationships with the world
and where within that system world model,
it has this kind of agent like a force
for me that counts.
But a
lot of people would disagree on that.
But for me, I think you're trying to find
the maximally
explanatory course screening
and sometimes that might be fine
at the level of the virtual machine and
not in terms of the physical realization.
And then that's
actually the most meaningful cause.
And then if you trace it out there,
that's where you would look for it.
And so that could be in the digital twin
or emulation,
but a lot of people
would disagree with that. Hmm.
So when you were talking
about applying this to the colony level,
I thought about
like the foraging behavior
that's like reaching out of the ground
and grabbing a seed.
And so that's like
the enacted foraging trip.
And then is there a counterfactual
I could be foraging or we could be
foraging at some different scale
underground
on the other side of the Marcott
blanket of the nest entrance.
And then what if somebody were going
to be tracking the elevation of a forager
and they'd be like, well,
they go up and down in the nest.
But on the times
where they make that decision to forage,
they always go up
200 milliseconds before foraging.
It's like, Well, yeah,
that's where the nest entrance is.
So without going into whether they have
will or not, it's like it's
some kind of cognitive motor
or integration
when the person hits the button.
So then the way that you frame this
as being like not a trivial artifact,
in fact,
an interesting outcome of aggregation
of ERPs across trials,
it's like
OK, wouldn't there be
a coherence preamble now?
I guess it doesn't.
If we're here for 30 seconds long,
that would be a different setting.
But then when we connect it
to the specific mechanisms by which
the do have to come together in order
for there to be a coherent motor action
it's it's quite an interesting view
and I wonder how those who
have interpreted it
in a very different way feel.
Have you spoken or asked to anyone
who has a very clear and
different interpretation
of what this potential means.
I've been discussing it
some with other or I forget.
I've been discussing some of them.
Or a good amount with them.
Are emails and Aaron Sugar.
Aaron. Sugar has.
A he has multiple.
Views but some of them do disagree
and so one of them
is you in theory because you're averaging
across multiple trials,
there is an interpretation of hardiness
potentials as artifactual
and it's possible that
sometimes you are dealing
with an artifact of measurement.
And this is an open question.
But he's also, for instance, a
very like he's, he's testing out
like the mental simulation view.
Also,
another interesting hypothesis
he has is actually some of the evidence
accumulation is actually fast
feedback loops with muscle spindles.
And actually you're getting basically.
The. Urge actually a lot of it
is actually in the body itself.
But one interesting thing for
I forget is that these.
Are like build up.
And then threshold crossing,
I believe this
you'll see across all nervous systems
where you get action selection.
And I would wonder
whether this similarly,
similarly to me saying like, you know,
this isn't just like a brain story.
Might we see
basically something like this
if we're looking at
I think in your activity paper,
you talk about like stigma, coherence,
but through some sort of like
forgive me if I'm
butchering it for like some sort of
like measure of the kind, you might see
something like generalized action
potentials for large scale changes in
switching modes of the hive
mind of the colony.
And I'm just speculating actually
also in terms of multi stage hierarchies.
I'm actually. Wonder.
Whether the.
Brains like for instance,
the resting state networks of the brain,
maybe not like there's different
like granularity and stations,
it can be as much as 17 or more
if you wanted.
But there there's some solutions
that are like maybe, you know, so
seven networks are most well known but
there's also like five network solutions.
And I'm wondering
if they're actually universality classes
for active inferential agents
that you'll actually get something
like Humalog of different rest
and say networks in their patterns
of effective connectivity
so generalized
resting state networks, generalized
phenomenon to like things like readiness
potentials.
Are very.
Very. Speculative.
But that's that's I think we might.
A few interesting things
that makes me think of
and are we making cognitive science
a creation in our own image
if we talk about the generalized
hippocampus and the general.
And so
to what extent are we or can we must we
generalize from our own action
perception loop
is putting another umbrella
which the human mind is
just a realization of and saying, well,
the cognitive
domain is bigger than the human brain
because it includes the brain body
and the extended niche,
but also includes non-human systems,
like if we want to cognitive science
that includes a thermometer
or something like that, like a thermostat
is that a
is that a cope?
Because actually that is still
the water that that model swims in
is still human
and cognitive like I don't know.
But these are interesting pieces.
I mean,
it seems like it seems like surely what
you're describing has to be the case.
And it's like OK.
And that's like a both a good thing
and a bad thing where it's like
we need to be able to draw.
On an.
Analogy with something we understand
like we're always like
where we we're usually making
sense of things in terms of other things.
And so like our own experience
as a space domain
in order to give us some purchase, like
can we do it without it?
You could say like
first principles thinking,
but like which first principles?
But then there's like all of the like.
The baggage
that could come like the distance
with like if you're if it seems like
we can't avoid doing that,
maybe we could, but if we want to
but then like we really need
to be careful to track the dis analogies.
Like if we're saying generalized
hippocampus, like, OK, wait, wait, wait.
What are the gist analogies here?
What are the proper
unique properties that are present
in the target domain and off the base?
Tomatoes like the map, that analogical
mapping you're doing or vice versa
yes. Yeah.
That's from what you're describing.
Yeah.
Well,
I think you're kind of closing area.
Just one point that I want to pick up on.
I thought it was really powerful
what you said
about really the social consequences
and the personal consequences of
interpretation of neurosciences.
And in some ways, even science
communication around empirical results,
like the idea that we could opt out
to free will
and that in a world
where there's limited degrees of freedom,
you might be coerced into thinking
you had free will or not.
But if there's any glimmer of free will,
it can be used to deny
and deceive itself.
So that puts research in this area in
a different reflexive position
than research on other systems.
So I guess just
how do we move forward here
while drawing on the specifics
and being respectful
of basically the past,
the present and the future
I mean.
For me, I definitely have a lot of
soul soul in the.
Game and that.
This is actually
maybe the biggest thing. The
couple of things with this
might have been one of the biggest things
that got me into cognitive
science was a very long extended.
Freak out about.
Free will
when I was younger, where I was just
I couldn't feel anything to be mean.
I couldn't see how anything
could be meaningful without it.
I don't know if I still believe
that exactly. But
for. Me it was it was very difficult. To.
Not believe that
there were like a sort of all or nothing
thinking about free will
and then going with the nothing.
Done.
It actually rescued me from that
with Freedom Evolves that has book, but
there was a long time
where it seriously bothered me
and it had real negative
consequences on my life.
The and I'm.
Not alone in this.
I've talked to others
and they also feel that way.
And part of.
The way this is coming up in the present
work with psychedelics actually is
so there's this study with
I'm preparing for with creative
professionals who are suffering from.
Burnout.
And one thing I'm.
Wondering in terms of like people
who have burnt out for multiple reasons,
but to the extent
that this is continuous with
burnout is continuous with. A.
Depression or like feeling
like you don't have agency in context
where you want to have agency
or feeling
like you don't have adequate control. Of.
Something,
where it really matters that you do
that seems like a good recipe
for burnout.
And it seems also like a decent model
for some forms of depression, where
if you view yourself as not being able
to be a cause in the world,
if you're not able to meaningfully work
towards your values,
that could be very distressing.
Maybe it could also be a state
of like a quasi Buddhist
sick, like blissful surrender. But,
you know, there's the question.
Are we flirting with nihilism?
There is a question.
And the other question is.
You know, is.
It even legitimate, though,
to be an element to this
on the self and on volition?
And then just to say it's OK,
you're not real.
Your volition isn't real
anyways, don't worry about it.
Was that even a legitimate intellectual
move to begin with?
I would argue it wasn't
so yeah.
I think this is the stakes here
for people's sense of themselves.
I believe they really matter,
and I believe they have both social and.
Clinical.
And social consequences,
existential consequences for people.
And I'm glad that there's this like
growing community of people in the neuro
philosophy of free will who have been
doing a really great job pushing
against like some of these, I believe,
excessively inflationary views.
And I believe
that active inference might be a really
valuable contribution to these efforts
in terms of providing formal models
and models that can go across this.
Marianne Neuro Phenomenological SAC
or computational nerve
phenomenological setup
and actually address these phenomena
in enough detail where not only can
we feel like
meaningfully satisfied,
where we understand our own agency,
but we could we could intervene
and hopefully for the better
yeah.
Just just some last thoughts on that.
That's very powerful.
And the the mutual constraints
and the interdependencies
of the different levels, like
it may come down to someone's
genetic sequence of a receptor or
some kind of
binding affinity with a molecule,
but then it could
also be integrated
in kind of a full stack way with
talk or action or changes to the niche.
So it gives like a full stack.
Yes. And way that's not
I think
a dead end.
It's more like a starting state,
like if the computer weren't working
and then there was like the hardware
and there's the software.
But then moving beyond
just that type of analogy,
which is very
powerful about burnout
and about the different cognitive ways
that we might get there and get into it
and get out of it.
And so it's like stoicism or whatever
plus preferences because
it's not just the neutral stance, it's
not just a descriptive stance on burnout.
There's like a preference there so Adam,
if you have any other thoughts,
please feel free.
I think it's a.
Quick thought
is if.
We're looking and this is like
to follow up on the comment or saying
like he's someone who just stick a limit
this framings of agency.
And I said like,
are they even legitimate?
I'm going to argue. No, they're not.
And specifically if we're thinking.
Of something like modeling.
The self through time
as a high level controller,
if you engage in some sort of practice,
whether it's discipline, meditation
for a long period times,
or you've taken like a very high dose
of psychedelics and you've basically.
Collapsed the depth of your.
Temporal depth and counterfactual
reactions to your generative.
Model, you will not find yourself,
you will be gone.
There will be.
No like you to talk about
and you might call this.
Ego death.
But then to say that there never was.
A due process to begin with.
I believe that is actually
illegitimate
you basically use the search strategy.
That.
Apriori should not have been able
to find the self.
And then using that search strategy,
you then concluded didn't exist.
And I think that just doesn't work.
So in.
This case.
You know, to quote it again.
Individuals, their narratives,
their persons.
You know.
Their real patterns. And
but they're.
Also there's a reflexive ness to where
their own belief and their own reality
is an important part
of their causal significance.
And so,
you know, I think it.
Would be good
to have some some nice debates
with like different members of the active
inference community who are more
deflation
theory on things like cells, self
processes and agency
because ultimately,
I think this is a thing where
it's going to be like, well, we should be
respectful and disagreements.
I think it really matters.
We get it right to the extent we can.
Thank you, Adam,
for the excellent presentation.
Apologies for any Internet glitches
that might have happened
we are a strange loop and this has been
a strange livestream.
Always good talking to.
You, Daniel.